we're going to talk about today so uh
obviously we're going to talk about
tooling i mean you probably got that
from the title
uh we're going to talk about quality but
more than quality we're going to talk
about enforcing quality
keeping the level of quality
the same not basically going worse
uh
but then i mean
keeping as good as you are is only one
part of the problem right you also want
to probably raise it from wherever it is
because
if if the bar is really low well you can
keep it there but that's probably not
the objective you have right you
probably want to upgrade it too and
we'll focus on automation because again
our programmers were lazy we like to
have somebody else do our job but still
get paid
and also i mean um this is the first the
first part is gonna be for your manager
because at some point you're gonna have
to make a case for it
because i mean that's the first thing
he's gonna ask like well that sounds
nice but how much is it gonna cost me
so this is basically what we're gonna
talk in the first part
because i i don't like i mean
i thought about this very hard when i
made this like yeah obviously we're
gonna you want this because of quality
and then i remember this talk i had with
a manager of mine a couple of times i
don't know exactly a couple years ago
maybe and he was like oh you engineers
you just want quality for quality sake
that's an engineering thing like yeah
you know we're nerds we just want
quality for quality there is like this
is the only reason we want it
this is not really true or so i hope uh
there's actual reasons why we want
quality it's just not because we're
being very pedantic
uh there's actual reasons and that's
that's what i try to uh to think about
so
what are the words that comes to mind
like okay let's you're my audience
that's perfect uh you have totally not
seen my my my twitter question before or
maybe you have if you follow me
what comes to mind if you think quality
i say like oh this code base is quality
what what do you expect
few bucks yeah that's that's a good one
actually i call it robustness
it's yeah it's rubbers you know what
it's tested it works it actually does
what it's supposed to do
that's one able to be changed oh did you
see two slides before or what
we have absolutely not coordinated
before just so you know okay
uh you can get a guess that there's at
least two more bullet points so what
what else is going to come in your in
your mind
cute cute
that's an interesting one that's not the
first one i would thought about but uh
i put ease of use like yeah so
basically yes it's robust it's
maintainable it's easy to use and since
your manager is maybe in the room it's
also cost you know because i mean we
were talking about this yeah okay we get
all that stuff but how much is it gonna
cost me
so let's talk about this thing
so robustness of course we mean bug free
but not only uh we also think about
other stuff like portability you don't
have to be 100 portable with platforms
you will never ship for but you have to
be reasonably portable
like probably try to not
abuse too much the online machine it
works thing uh not rely on undefined
behavior and that kind of stuff
because i mean software changes and
maybe at some point you will have to
move to 64 bits like i did in three
different projects or uh you will have
to go on another operating system or you
will just get a new version of the
compiler and
if it actually works because you're
relying on implementation b for the
defined stuff and you may have some
issues
unique test coverage is also a thing i
mean i don't even know how you guarantee
robustness without unique test coverage
you can probably manual test but
it has some limits
and error handling this is probably the
one that uh was suggested the less or
that here the less uh when people think
about robust code it's how well do you
handle errors not only like you actually
handle them which is like a first
uh but the second one is like you you
tell either the programmer or the user
which might be a programmer what
happened and what can you do or what can
you do about it
uh i make video games right so i think a
lot about ux and i think i know people
hate when you go just get a pop-up
saying err
that doesn't help anybody
so yeah i think erin link is probably
the the one that is uh thought less the
for the less when we talk about quality
when we talk about maintainability
it usually goes hand in hand i think
with simplicity right like the simplest
code is used to uh to maintain because
it's like so dumb you can't you can it's
foolproof you can't you can't you can't
you can't you can't miss it
uh expressiveness also comes together
like if your code is expressive it's
easier for people who get into it to get
the intent of what you're doing and say
oh wait a minute that doesn't make sense
or oh yeah sure it's doing that sure oh
yeah okay i get it
if it's sophisticated with like
basically uh like a huge blocks with f
and continues and fourth and over block
and then the go-to maybe
uh it's gonna be much harder to maintain
uh it might work but the minute someone
tries to change something it's gonna run
into a world of pain
uh use of common items uh we hire people
from time to time uh or we move
companies
and uh i mean the only shared knowledge
we really have is stuff that is already
used somewhere else and that's that's uh
cognitive uh load basically the less i
have to learn the better right i um
my previous company had these
interesting items that uh if i didn't
believe in new and delete or unlock and
free everything was called open and
close
and the first time the first time i i
saw the idea of opening and closing an
array i was very confused
how do you open an array like that
like a socket i would have understood a
file i would have understood but an
array how do you open it how do you
close it so many questions
well that's less questions if you use
something common and usually we think
about like
either design patterns you already know
about but also vocal vocabulary types
are you don't have to use the stl if you
don't like to and see my other talk but
you uh you can still have an interface
that looks like it enough so that people
are not confused
uh and of course clean architecture is
usually also a big big plus for
maintainability uh the minute you start
wanting to uh to change stuff uh if if
you have circular dependencies or just
kind of messy architectures you will run
into
well
many problems
ease of use of course like
again quality code you want uh you want
to um you you want a good you want a
good api design you want an api that is
uh i think it's scott mayer we said like
make it easy to use and very hard to
misuse i'm not sure it's got mayors
actually uh
work from home uh if you if you can tell
me but yeah
make the thing easy to use uh and very
hard to use the wrong way uh
that that's that's that's that's i think
something we we have in some parts of
the stl maybe not so less
in others but some frames are very
straightforward you just
you will really have to want to uh to
mess it up like if you don't try
explicitly to mess it up it will
probably do whatever you expect
documentation comes with that uh doesn't
have to be like actual uh physical
documentation or just like uh readme or
there is
a lot of way of doing documentation but
at least some documentation at least
even a comment saying this is my
precondition this is my post condition i
expect this pointer to not be null i
expect you to give me only positive
integers that kind of stuff
uh because again if not you create
assumptions and then it's not easy to
use because if you rely on assumptions
you may have problems
and genericity because again you want to
reuse it and the more generic it is the
easier it is to reuse that that's why we
usually like like stuff like templates
algorithms and all that stuff because
it's reusable in other cases
okay so far i talked about stuff that
most people in the room oh you're not
gonna tell me is it the kind of stuff
you want to see
are you are we are we clear on the idea
that sounds like quality stuff that
sounds like something i want to make
codebase
yeah
i see people like yeah yeah we should do
that um that's cool but then your
manager comes it's like okay cost
because i mean
you you talk about all that things and
the first question is gonna have a yes
but can you do this for free like it's
gonna cost something right i mean if i
had if i had to choose for bad to good
code and both of them would cost the
same thing i would only have good code
so obviously it must cost something and
i mean sure it is like you might have
development time overhead because i
guess it takes more time to think that
to not think
and then we run into the ideas of
technical depth uh because
actually you um you have something that
technical lab is a form of cost is you
don't want to pay something and then it
keeps creeping
possibly less than if you actually did
the investment but it's still it's still
a cost that that's lying somewhere it's
the fact that every time you try to add
more stuff for your code base it just
cost you and cost here
even if at the time it was cheap to make
and then of course we tile that to the
big old idea of return of investment
it's like sure you can give me quality
but how do i get my money back as a as
as someone who's actually like paying
your salary or if you own your own
company or someone who's just like
funding the project how am i getting my
money back because quality is great but
what do i get out of it is it is it
worth it
and you know that's the base quality is
quality worth the cost
uh i'm not going to say yes or no
because that's not a really yes no
question like there is a gradient to
everything right like the more you put
into quality
maybe the less you'll get maybe not
that's that's a question i think we
should we we need to explore before we
go on um i have my opinions but
let's let's see where it led
so the thing when we enter the debate of
course versus benefits for quality is
that actually
it's kind of bizarre because
some parties actually are easy to
measure for the cost of quality if you
ask your manager is going to be very
easy to measure it's like okay extra
developer time that's fine that's
something you can understand it will
pull up an excel sheet and multiply
every monday by one point something one
point two one point three two three four
times i don't know it's something you
can easily measure it's overhead it's
gonna cost me more mandates to get
anything done okay that's easy resource
investment same thing i need to buy
servers i need to buy licenses i need to
buy hardware but okay it's easy i can
put a number on this like i i buy x
machines multiply blah blah blah blah
the accounting and all that stuff is
fairly straightforward there's still a
figure of like it's not precise silence
but you can get a pretty decent ballpark
number
benefits on the other hand
how do you put a price
on quality like on how much you gain
from it like okay let's say from now on
we focus on portability
and before we didn't how much how much
money do i get like
i can i can quantify man hours and then
make a multiplication by the cost i'm
paying my guys and get an idea of how
much i'm gonna pay
how do i know if it's actually worth it
because that's the thing like how do you
evaluate future time not spent because
that's usually that right like you have
quality
because in the future your stuff will
not be cost you to to maintain or even
maybe maybe cheaper to maintain
you won't have to spend as much time on
bug fixing or on uh debugging stuff
but that's
that's money i won't have to spend how
do i quantify money i won't have to
spend it's like selling insurance it's a
whole job like there are people paid
reasonable amount of money to make
mathematical models that tell you how
much should an insurance cost depending
on how much you get and then you start
getting into probabilities
i'm not a math person i i have no idea
how to compute that i don't know if
anyone in the room does that's that's
great for you but i don't think i do and
i'm not sure my manager wants to bother
with that either
and also potential damage is over that's
really the insurance part because like
yeah how much would it cost me
if there was a critical bug in my
application and i get like i don't know
a big crash uh like i mean the the
the worst example is like my like the
the people who cut some costs on the
fourth and then we use the code on ion
the fifth and then it blew up like
how do you manage the fact that maybe by
skipping some codes now we might lose a
rocket in 10 years how do you even
compute that or you get a data breach or
whatever else it's very hard to compute
and i think that's the biggest problem
when you try to argue quality with
someone
is that one of them is easy to measure
the other one
it's very intangible it's just an id
but there are actual arguments you can
make that are much more concise and um
the first one is
okay
who here uh oh let's let let's not let's
not spoil you okay here is the thing
you you you can disagree with me but i
really think that regardless of quality
companies view the code you write as an
investment
and what i mean by that is that
if you go to your boss and say okay we
shipped the server uh the service i can
throw away all the code now what is the
first thing is gonna say what no are you
crazy no we spend so much money
developing that of course we're gonna
reuse it
like we're gonna make more features or
maybe we're gonna make a sequel or uh
maybe we're gonna do something else like
i wanna try with you
let's let's try something
how many projects did you start or
joined right just to think about the
number in your head okay
you get an id how many projects you
started by your own or just join during
your career okay fine
how many of those were killed
like oh not in production today nobody
developing them anymore
is that more than zero
good
how many of those have never been reused
in any other project either
does anyone has a non-zero value
oh two three people in the room
right
as far as i know as far as you know yeah
you left the company maybe
so yeah and i think that's the biggest
idea like
um there was a very great talk about
this mum sadly it's in france uh when
someone was saying basically accounting
views of my of my code as as destroy the
iit model and the argument it was making
is that
your software has paid dividends at the
moment you shipped you shipped it you
you got a contract you got clients it's
it's paid off you should not look at it
like someone looks as a piece of
furniture about and say oh no we have to
amortize this in five years
like the accounting thing they teach you
when you start taking accounting classes
every time you buy something there is
something called amortization you say
okay
every year i'm gonna devaluate the value
on my on my company
assets and at some point it will be zero
and when it's zero i can safely throw it
away because it's been properly
amortized in accounting they never do
they kind of do that in software even if
but they not always
decide to go to zero it might you know
go down and down but not really
and and i think that's the big problem
because
here's the thing
code always lives longer than projected
a couple of times i tried like i was
maybe younger i thought okay i have a
very tough decision to make i can take a
shortcut or i might not take a shortcut
but i know one of them is going to cost
more so i'm going to ask my boss how
long is this project going to last
because then i can actually make a cost
versus benefit ratio
but whatever number i got was never the
right result right like if it was
honestly said i don't know
if it was not he would say i don't know
three months and then we'll never use it
again
yeah no that's not gonna happen
like unless your company goes under or
uh
something terrible happens most of your
code is gonna live longer than you it
and then it brings the question right
it's not that expensive to get quality
uh i mean it is but not as much as you
might think
one of the big reasons is automation and
that's what we're going to talk about
for the rest of this talk
uh
a lot of quality uh checks and
and guarantees and other stuff like that
can can be attained
at a very reasonable cost
and more importantly especially when we
get to the automation parts uh that that
helps you making your code better
it's done by cpus it's vulnerable
machines and if there is one thing
automation has told us is that machines
are much cheaper than humans and this is
the further the exact reason why we have
those jobs it's because someone figured
out that it's cheaper to pay someone to
make a program and then run the program
that have people do the thing manually
every time and that's the exact same
thing with code
so here's the thing
in my opinion
and feel free to disagree with me in
this talk or after the talk and and tell
me i'm wrong but here's the case i think
you can make for quality is that whether
you like it or not whether you admit it
or not your code will be seen as an
investment by your company
and if i have to pick between a bad code
and a good code i think one of them is a
better investment
and then how much
you have to put on that investment well
with tooling i think it can be
reasonable
so let's see what we can do with that
i call this section by bare bones
the reason is called bare bones is well
because it's the bare bones it's all the
stuff that i think every project should
have
but also
it might sound dumb but
over the past couple years i maybe
worked on three or four different
projects in different companies none of
them have had all of this at the time
when i joined them and i'm not sure all
of them have all of them
sorry i'm not sure
all of those programs have all of those
projects have all of those things in
them so
we'll play a game okay
we'll uh we'll check them and we'll see
with the room it does everybody had
everything and then and then you will
tell me if it's if i'm really speaking
about stuff that is so obvious that
everybody has it because i'm pretty sure
it's not
it's me of course we're gonna talk some
build but don't worry there's like two
slides
so step zero is a reproducible build oh
god that word
reproduce
build
you need one
i know you don't want to talk about bill
i know because i talk about bill and
nobody else wants to uh
but you need to and here's why the idea
is that you have two developers
it scales to more than two but we have
three quantities in computer science
right like one two and many you know
zero one and many so two is many you
have at least two people and they both
uh pull the same sources same version
same comments same revision whatever you
use same physical copy if you don't use
scms
i didn't put scm i just assume you use
that that i i don't go that bad
uh and then they could build
both of them
and then they should get the exact same
program
all the exact same error message
if one of them gets a program and the
other one gets a compiler or you have no
you don't have a reproducible build
if two people gets a program but they
differ
significa and they differ in the code
like in the binary generated in ways
that they basically don't behave the
same or if they don't get the same error
message but they both get an error
message you don't have a pretty super
mobile what
i mean like
i mean
up to some extent probably i mean you
may have time stamps and a bunch of
other stuff in your code but
except timestamps and other things that
like observable stuff should be the same
like your behavior should be exactly the
same you shouldn't have one that that
says one and the other one that says two
uh when you put the same input into it
unless you're actually testing a random
term number generator but then how do
you that's that's a tricky question
yeah so basically the idea is i built
the same program twice uh on the same
machine or i built the same program once
on two different machines
with the same source with the same tool
chain blah blah blah i get the exact
same result because we're here to talk
about automation
and how do you do automation if it's not
reproducible
what do you do when you get false
positives you start distrusting the
system
and if you can't trust it you can't use
it
and that's as simple as that if you have
false positives in your build then whole
automation is out of the window that's
that's why it's step zero and that's the
first thing you should address if you
don't have replicable build well every
automation you put there
it says green but is it really i don't
know
i remember last week it said green and
then it actually didn't build or it said
red and it was actually fine but on my
machine it worked
that doesn't work
you don't have to do full very complex
build system you don't even have to let
me talk to you about cmake it can just
be like build.sh and gcc star
oh like i don't care
the important part is i run this script
and i ever get the same message error
message or i get the same program at the
end if i don't get that i don't have a
reproducible build and then i cannot
automate anything
uh if you have tests i mean obviously
you should have tests right uh
the the build common should probably
also build the test and run them and the
same way your uh your build is uh is no
is reproducible your test should be
reproducible if i if i run the same time
to test twice
they should both pass or both fail for
the same test and the same reason
if i run them on two machine same story
again
it's about making sure you don't have
false positives because then you start
distrusting the system and you cannot
automate it
so yeah if you want to walk out of this
room with one thing and then just work
out everything else i say maybe remember
just this randomness is the nemesis of
automation
if you have randomness automation will
just fail
step one yeah zero was build i'm a
programmer i started zero
uh or maybe it was because you need that
to go through it anyway automated
formatting
who here likes to argue about formatting
yeah we're programmers we like to argue
way too many you know what
i think whatever the reason the response
i get to this question i push my points
both way right i know you care way too
much or you don't care at all but in in
both cases it's going to be terrible
uh because i mean i don't know about you
but to me manual formatting is a waste
of time and the only thing that is worse
is debating formatting
i think
i've been in three code standard
initiatives so far that i failed because
some people started argues types of
spaces versus braces on the next line
like
i don't care
i don't care as long as client format
can format it
just give me the clan format file and i
will do whatever i have to do i will put
some plug in my id or i would put a git
comic code and he will just do it
there are several reasons why you want
to do that uh i guess the biggest one is
that you're going to have
we're going to have to start doing some
more advanced automation down the line
and that won't work if you conform at it
because humans can format but
robots they need rules to format they
can't just read your google doc code
standard and format with it but it's not
going to work
also i think devs are much more readable
if you actually only care about that
because you can just ignore the white
space changes
i mean you can do whatever you want i i
don't even have an opinion on this i
mean
i have several opinions but
whatever works as long as everything you
comment is formatted using the code the
formatting standard you saved uh and it
could be the standard the default one
from from clang or one of the five or
six styles it comes with or it could be
your custom one i don't really care as
long as there is one
um most ideas of plugins i think i say
most because i don't know all ids
but yeah all ids as
a plugin that on save or on demand can
apply clan format on the whole file and
then you can have a pre-commit hook on
good on git if you really want to be
sure that everything that you commit is
formatted it just has to be
yeah because if you don't have that then
somebody will not do it and then you
don't want it to save then you make a
small change and the whole file changes
right so here's the thing the first time
you moved to formatting if you did not
have it before
yes you must have heavy file and some
people will argue oh but no it's going
to break my my history and i will never
be able to do git blame for the rest of
my life
well this is not true anymore and it's
been some time now git as a great
comment say uh argument that says ignore
refs file which is just every time you
make a white space change to your code
base that like you and you apply clan
format everywhere
you just make it you make only that
changes in the comments only that and
nothing else i mean that and submitting
the new clan format file
and then you note down that uh
that clang for that that commit id and
you write it you you push it on the next
comment
and get
and then you say every time you do git
blame you can tell get ignore that
comment it's white space i don't care
about it
because sure i've done it in the past
i've done clan format everywhere and and
and then some very uh
basic people at qa put every bug on me
because every time they did git blame
that was my line that was changed that
was great i got all the tickets from the
department that was fun
but then well you just do that and then
it doesn't happen anymore because it
goes through and it doesn't exist it's
it's as if git did not see it you can
still
you can still not pass the arguments if
really you have a doubt that your two
formative has made a bug but 99 of the
time you want and you can just ignore
that entirely and the argument goes out
of the window
and every time you change the style you
just add one more one one thing to the
ref style and it's just as if it never
happened
step two
merge requests
who here is not using merge requests
it's fine
i understand you when i joined my
company we was not using merge request
either
why why are metric was great
code reviews
yes but not exactly
see i can remember because i could do
code reviews after the fact
sure yep
i haven't made statistics so i will make
this claim uh kind of out of my ass but
i'm pretty sure it's right it's like
any review of comments you made after
the comment was merged into whatever
integration branches needs to be
as
i don't know 10
chance maybe of being acted upon because
you know it's merged
you can close the jira it's like
documentation you will do it later
yeah i used to have a workflow that was
yeah no we you merge first and then you
like every week or something you're
supposed to look at the history and
you just check the comments and make
comments oh i made tons of comments but
you know the good thing about comments
were ignored when you compile well
that's the exact same thing with this
you can just ignore them
so
basically the idea is that no change
should be merged unless someone has
reviewed and approved it
end of the line and how do you do that
you do that with pull requests because
with pull requests you force
contributors to address your concern or
not be able to close vergiera
or whatever tracking bug system you use
if they cannot close their task because
they have not addressed your comment
well they will actually address your
comment because that's the only way they
get anything through the door
if you say no no you can address them
later
i mean how willing are you to take that
chance
maybe if you trust them you know
wherever they live maybe you can
but uh yeah i wouldn't take it
no i would lock the integration branch
every
gitlab git blah blah gitlab github git
whatever we all have this you lock
nobody is right nobody can do anything
on that branch even the tech lead nope
nobody even the ceo nobody can push
nobody
but they can do merge requests
but only if someone has actually
approved them
and then you can change the code and
that's the only way in
because again we're going to do quality
and the only way to assert in quality is
that everything is up to the standard if
there is a shortcut
and then there is a way
and you know people take the path of
least resistance because that's human
you have a deadline you want to go home
i've done it i'm not proud of it but
i've done it
and i said like but it's just me it's
fine
ah i know what i'm doing
or i just need to go home ah we are
super good at making excuses for
ourselves and it's it's normal and
psychology has a lot of article about
that it's it's we need someone else to
keep us in check basically and that's
the thing and also reviewers are not
limited to humans you can have robots
reviewing you
and we're going to have some robots
reviewing ourselves i work in sci-fi
unless you have adopt
and we're going to see that but first we
need continuous integration
who else who here has a ci
ah i'm starting to lose hands
interesting i should have done this for
every step
all right
so the idea is that your reference
branch or integration branch your master
you develop your whatever you call it
should always build and pass the tests
that's that's the basic idea because
that's how you assert in quality you
make sure that nothing that gets merged
is actually bad and the first step of
not being bad is probably compiling the
second step is passing the tests the
first step is passing reviews
we've used we concerned that with the
previous steps which was merge request
now we need to make sure it actually
builds
and it actually uh passed the tests
so how do we do it it's easy
you remember that a script we made on
step zero that had to be always uh right
or wrong but never kind of right but
kind of wrong
well that's why we have it
because then we can just make sure that
every time something is pushed on the
master branch or on the whatever branch
the bot runs and then it tells everybody
stop whatever you're doing it should not
be red
and actually we can take that a step
further and say you know what
my robot can run on any merge request
because what's a merge request is the
sum of whatever we have plus whatever
you want to add which is
usually exactly what you will end up
with if you click that merge button
unless you're not using fast forward and
uh
but i mean that's semantics we can argue
about them later but the biggest idea is
like okay now we have a second review
release also mandatory
pull request and it's a robot
and until the robot is happy you're not
merging
because if the robot is unhappy well it
probably has a good reason to be unhappy
because it's a very very dumb and very
very stupid script that just says yes or
no and he only says no when you have
something critical like you could not
building
and that's very simple
and that way again
you can't just go home and say i i yeah
i don't pass the test but it's fine or
you don't have like oh who brought the
bill oh it's it's it's uh it's john but
he went on vacation
sorry let's fix the build i'm away all
my mails are redirected to the trash
and we're done with the basics who has
all the basics
hey
i still have some people cool
there is a few issues when you start
doing that so i will try to address them
real quick
the first one is randomness did i talk
about randomness yet okay
if you have randomness you have problems
the most classic one is the buildbot
sometimes is red but it's not actually
red
you know what happens when you do that
you may you start making it optional
because you might be have to override
them because you know sometimes he says
it's failed but it does not really fail
so you're like ah ignore the butt he's
wrong merge
and the longer you do that the longer
someone will say you know what maybe i
don't have to wait for the bill to the
the bot to build i mean it's gonna it's
gonna have the time it's just gonna give
me technical errors anyway
and people don't like to waste time they
hate wasting time on bad automation even
worse than they uh that they like
wasting time with no automation
like that automation is even worse than
automation
so if you want to do it and again we're
doing quality you have to make it right
so randomness again it's a problem
you may have some i mean i'm not i
you you have like you can have like a i
don't know like if one every thousand
build as a technical issue because your
servers are out of space i mean it's not
great you can try to have something that
is good enough to be able to recoup from
that but i mean it's not the end of the
world
if like half your bill fail for random
reasons or even ten percent right then
you have a problem
another draw another problem that people
usually break up bring up when i talk
about this is a build job duration the
fact that oh but i have to wait for the
build job to compile and test all my
code before i can merge
well my first question i have is like ho
ho or her how in your area are you for
to get your code to merge like it does
it have to be like in five minutes
can we wait an hour
i mean maybe in some cases you have a
merge request that cannot wait an hour
but most of the time you will also need
i mean all the time you will need a
human reviewer too and i hope you don't
run to your colleagues every time you
push a miracle saying no no stop
whatever you're doing give you my code
now
i mean i don't know about you but i just
opened the merge request like a couple
times a day a day like maybe two free
and i said oh there's something i could
review now because i have nothing else
to do and then i review code chances are
the bot is done anyway at this point
because it's been an hour
if your bot takes 12 hours then yes that
might become a problem for your workflow
and then you might have two other issues
maybe you need to split the project you
probably need to improve your build
process but i mean then again if your
build job takes 12 12 hours how long
does your local build takes
there's a huge chance it's going to be
the same issue and means you can't
iterate either so
i understand the arguments but i think
it's probably overused for what it
actually is because again
i don't think you should rush on a code
review on a merge request unless
everything is on fire but then again the
more quality you have the less chances
something is going to be on fire anyway
and we can always argue about
exceptional uh measures for exceptional
cases right we can always make small
exceptions maybe you take lead
in very small condition could be allowed
to touch directly the master branch blah
blah blah but again
exceptions
oh and randomness is also bad
okay
let's get something a bit more advanced
so that everybody in the room gets
something
um so the first thing you're going to do
is talk about build because again me
because here is the thing uh all the
tools i showed up to there are very
simple uh client format for example does
not need to be able to pass your code uh
like it works on the tokenizer it
doesn't actually need to uh to to to do
the ast parsing and all that stuff
uh more advanced tools need to see as
much as your compiler does is need to be
able to read all your code the same way
your compiler would do it needs to have
the right include paths you need to have
the right defines you need to have
everything the same way as if you were
compiling
because else is not reasoning on the
same code
it has to because it defines a bunch of
if def and a bunch of other stuff
which basically means every time he
wants to analyze a file with some
like advanced
tools you need to get the full compile
command to compile it
uh there are several way you can
communicate that to a tool the most
common one is the llvm compiler databa
compilation database and i think it's
probably based on the fact that a lot of
people use clang based tooling which is
great and probably the rest of uh of the
content of this first section
the good news is if you use cmake it's
one line you'd have minus dc make export
compile commands to your uh when you run
cmake and it just generate that file for
you and i've
yet to see it fair even with the ugliest
build i've seen in cmake and trust me
people send me c make lists sometimes
it works it's just like it should work
if you're running an exotic build system
or custom build system because you
brought your own because it's fun and
whatever
then you need to bake that support in
um that was a there was a problem in a
previous job of mine
we made their own build system and one
day i say
since we switched that thing i can't do
any automation anymore because i can't
get the compilation database
that's that's not cool because you need
it
uh so yes
if it's you make it's easy if it's not
the best option i found was bear which
is a magic unix command that you uh you
call on top of your build and it will
try to intercept every cisco to a fork
basically and exec and try to say oh
you're trying to run gcc let me recall
that you're going to compile this file
it's kind of hacky
it's basically recording everything you
do when you run make
and from that it tries to infer what is
your build command
it's not super it's it kind of works but
it also doesn't work if you build on
visual studio and other issues like that
so i mean your best bet is cmake or some
tool that actually supports a little vm
i think bazel has one but i don't know
about the other ones some of them do
because we're going to do static
analysis next
we here uses aesthetic analyzer
okay who is not using clogged id of this
one
i think one p one person two person oh
free person what are you using
lens
lens
oh okay like the original no it's a oh i
don't think i used that one
oh i used pcb check
i had so many
false positives
but your mind age may vary i i mean
clank is going to be used for the rest
of this exploration but
if you find one that works for you just
it's fine it's good i'm not going to say
don't use it go ahead
i just figured out that cpp check was
too slow usually compared to clank tidy
but then again that's that's my uh
that's my that's my id so c plus plus is
a static list type language i i say
strongly but i know some haskell people
are gonna disagree with me um
semantically it's not strong but also
compared to c or javascript
your mileage may vary but the idea is
that the compiler can reason a lot about
the logic of your code right and that's
why the optimizer is so good it's
because it can blaze through a lot of uh
type in direction and all that stuff and
say yeah okay i see what you mean but i
can also conflate all that tree into
one's a very simple thing well
the same way if you
give the same kind of tool more time and
more exploratory algorithm they can
figure out a lot of stuff and that's
basically how static analyzers
work so it's more than bug checking bank
checking is the first thing they can
tell you but it's not only that uh for
example if you look at the client id
checks they have a lot of code standard
conformance like google says don't use
this use that i think llvm mozilla and a
bunch of others have contributed their
own checks to client id and the whole
idea is the same it's like our company
has a code standard that says you should
use those patterns and not lose patterns
you can have a tool that tells people oh
you're breaking the code standard there
fix it or you're not going to merge
you can suggest better better items and
we're going to talk about modernizing in
the next section but that's the big
classic like uh maybe you should use
otto there or have you heard about this
thing called rye
or
arrange for a bunch of other stuff like
that there's also a few checks that can
actually find sub-optimal bits of codes
uh the classic one i see is usually uh
mr opportunity for move like the places
where you should just have to move but
you did not and then you're gonna anchor
a copy when you could just not do it
the compile again a lot of those things
look like what you could get with a w
all the warnings of earth but uh
i think to some extent uh compiler
developers restrain themselves of how
many warnings their puts especially if
it requires deep analysis of uh of of
the call stack or uh of because i mean
people complain a lot about compilation
time already
so better put those checking in
in a dedicated tool that you can
use afterwards
so yeah i mean again clank id is my
recommendation if you find another one
great for you clank id is like 100
configurable checks at least
uh and also the big thing it has it can
suggest patches uh it can say yeah you
know what your code is not great here
but here is what you could do here is a
patch just just put it to patch and then
you're done
uh and also since it's clank it's super
modular and you can extend it and as we
will see next it's interesting you can
do a lot of stuff with that
how do you got how do you get from from
no static analysis to static analysis
because that's one of the things i hear
sometimes like oh yeah that sounds super
cool
but my code base is probably a billion
uh violation of all those how do i do it
and i would say it's the exact same way
you add warnings to your compiler that
you did not use before you check out a
branch
you add the warning or you had the check
on the on on your static analyzer you
run it you fix all the errors
when all the errors are fixed yay you
could merge
and then every new code will run with
that flag and then we'll check for it
and won't get merged unless it's fixes
and you just repeat the process until
you have enough and since the idea is
that quality can be iterative you will
probably never have enough you will
always find oh there is this new check
that we could introduce next
just my recommendation is doing step by
step don't try to put like clank tidy
minus everything
because yeah you're gonna have like so
many errors your terminal might crash or
something like no don't do that
but
pick a select ones fix go again like you
don't go from no warning to mine to
minus wall minus w error in one go like
that that's just insane you go you go
step by step
and again like i said and that's the
next section uh
you don't always have to do it yourself
again we want to automate and that's
that's where the big part comes in and
that's where the automation part of
automation comes because like automate
automation of compilation autumn like
pull request that's that's arguably some
form of automation but here is the here
is to me the big game changer
is that
a lot of refactoring is actually quite
systematic i mean it's supposed to be
systematic that's the point right you
replace python pattern a by person b
so you might start with like a control h
like search and replace in some in in
simple cases it works
and then you start getting creative say
you know what i think with a regex i
could match everything
maybe usually you stop being unable to
beat the regex before it actually does
everything you want oh at least that's
my uh that's my that's my usage like i
can write the regex but i basically
debugging the regex as i write it and
once it's executed there is no way i can
read it together
so
and the big thing we can do instead is
ast matching uh for i have not explained
it before but est is abstract syntax
tree
it's the tree representation of your
program basically as seen by the
compiler
and uh and and the big idea is that with
that we can uh we can start doing uh
queries on your code and then basically
replacements for example uh one of the
things you could do is say okay
uh i want to find all the functions uh
in my code that uh take an argument uh
that is passed by construct that they
got from their signature and then store
them in an internal class variable
like you you take like a string by
construct and you copy it basically
let's make a copy
and since you plus plus 11 we know that
it's sub-optimal you should take them by
refresh and you should stud move them
the reason is if you get called by a
temporary you save one more you save one
copy if you get called by something that
was about to be destroyed someone can
just pass it to you and again you save
the copy and i mean it's it's for string
it's all vector is for anything that is
kind of heavy to move
that would be very painful to do
manually i don't even know how i would
do that with reg access i mean it might
be possible if you have like a very very
good naming pattern that can detect like
stuff but no the solution is like oh hey
clang don't you have something that says
yeah you should modernize your code and
pass by value when you can
and then you just do that and then clank
will just emit patches that you just
have to uh
to to put in your code base and then and
then you're done
there's a lot of them
in modernize uh i've used them several
times uh historically a lot of migration
from uh after i migrated from 03 to 11
but also when i was wanting to migrate
from 11 to 4 to 14 or 17. uh for example
you can replace all the news by make
unix because naked new is bad but sadly
c plus 11 missed make unique for some
reason he was missed and he only ended
up in 14. so today you had a 14 you can
just say hey you know what remove all
those uh new expression ugly thing that
you do you can just make make unique
everywhere it's just cleaner uh you can
force o2 and range for everywhere that
it makes sense
uh when you start immigrating to 14 and
70 and you want to get rid of the auto
pointer you might have a new code base
the good thing is that there is a check
for that you might get
you won't get away with a control h
because you have to actually explicitly
start movement now and clan can do that
for you
you can remove a lot of code by saying
you know what you can just do a default
value equal default equal delete instead
of whatever tricks we used in all three
that's another big one and i think
that's i mean that's not all of them
that's just like four or five of the one
i used
there's like 10 of them or something now
maybe more they keep adding any more and
more
as time passes
so yeah basically the idea is that you
can do a lot of things you can
remove duplicated stuff
to help you like migrate code
you can
adopt new patterns by replacing old
constructs and all the
all items by something more more recent
and more modern
uh you can some cases find sub-optimal
call it's probably the least one uh the
list i i used it for but it's possible
there's a bunch of performance check and
clank tidy that kind of do the track
but the biggest thing is it's systematic
it's all across the card base well i
mean oh yeah it is all across the code
base you just fit all the cpp file you
have
and it will just do it for all of them
you won't miss anything
um if you want an example
actually the thing is it's only the
starting point
because okay sure you can i have done it
i have applied it to my code basis but
then i i eat another problem it says
sometimes there are patterns in my code
that are not really like common items
but i know they're bad i know i want to
migrate them
but i don't know how like ctrl h will
not work for example
what do i do
and the thing is since it's based on
clang you can write your own
you write a piece of c plus plus that
basically act as a as a matcher you you
match you match three expressions
basically and with and then you can say
okay for all the expression you matched
emit this code in replacement
and then it just generates a patch that
you can apply
if you want an example
um one i know
previous company of mine
who remembers f right table strings
anyone ever use that
okay back in the days a long time ago uh
c compilers would uh put uh
like uh
literal string literals in the in in the
data segments you could you could modify
them
quickly enough someone realized it was a
very bad idea said no it should be in
the text segment because obviously those
things are const
right you should not be able to modify
your string literal because it's not
supposed to be changed
uh but we already had code at the time
and instead of fixing it because that
means introducing some cons left and
right we just say no no we just use dash
f writable string somewhere i don't know
it was in the 90s i guess
uh and that that that helped for some
time
up until you say we're dropping if right
table strings
you can't have it
you want to upgrade your compiler
you need to get rid of it
and then you look at your code it's like
oh
this has been 15 years since we just
continued adding more and more of that
and the funny thing about constants it's
viral right
like it's not enough to just
figure out every place is when someone
takes a string literal and make const in
front because it passes to other apis
which also did not care about cons
constant took everything by a
non-constraint and non-conspirator
so what do we do well we take an expert
from the company and we say you fix this
because we need to upgrade
he does that for about couple months
and then he goes to his manager and he's
like you put me on another project or
i'm i'm out
i think we burn three programmers like
that
the fourth one says no way i'm not gonna
burn like those three
i'm gonna make i'm gonna study this
thing and i'm gonna make a bot that's
just gonna do it for me recursively like
basically it starts at level zero it has
constant everywhere and then it fixes
the uh the irregularity all the way down
the apis and that's the only way we
could switch from uh i don't know if
what's your cc free i think
that's the only way we could upgrade
from gcc3 to gcc 405 at the time and we
that was stocking uh that was blocking
us from moving to c plus plus 11 way
into the 2010s because we were using a
feature from an old gcc and there was no
way we could get it anymore i don't
think we ever tried
paying them for getting it hopefully we
didn't anyway
we managed to do it and the reason we
managed to do it at the time was because
of that
without it i don't i don't know if we
could have made it i think we would have
just stayed in c plus plus or three say
ah okay i guess white table strings
or we would have burned more programmers
i'm not sure we would even have achieved
it
so yeah the big idea is your code
becomes a database
like you code is data right yeah we we
usually say code is code and data is
data we're in two segments that's
obvious but your code is actually a
database because you can parse it you
can read it as a tree
and it's a tree and everything has types
and everything like that
and once it gets a tree well it becomes
a database and once it's a database
what's the thing you can do in the
database well you can query of course
but you can insert you can update you
can delete
and and that just opens up another
paradigm it's like you code these data
and since it's data you can basically
run migration steps the same way you
update your sql database
saying find everything that looks like
this and replace it like that
or just simply tell me how many rows
match this expression
this is things i should probably fix
and again at a large scale
i heard something like google invested
so much into this that they have more
bots than humans making comments on the
code base at this point
but basically run by robots
robots are cool
i made a sci-fi game
so yeah um i think user-defined
refactoring is really the next step and
this is where you are you go from like
cool tooling to really oh okay
we we can actually
take a significant uh part of our tech
depth and just chug it away by having uh
automated uh uh
uh process just taking care of it for us
like i would say it's kind of a shortcut
to pay back your tax debt i'm not saying
it's a good way so it's i mean some
people might argue that it's an argument
for tag them saying hey you know what
you have bots to fix it now i'm not sure
it's actually a good one but
whatever
in any case you can also introduce
breaking changes because
one of the problems i also saw in a lot
of code bases that nobody thought it
could actually fix
like change in api entirely and that's
one of the big reasons for example in c
plus plus we refuse to deprecate stuff
until we unless it takes a long time to
change
because there is always going to be
people raising their hand and say oh i
have
15 000 uses of photo pointer in my code
you can't duplicate it
i need that
and then you can say here here's a
script run it on your code base and now
you don't have an argument anymore and
now we can actually move forward and and
now you don't have to have like an api
with free overloads and have the
arguments are in use but you're still
keeping them because
because you don't want to change the
code base with that kind of stuff
you can fix your project and even better
if you publish a library and you're
afraid your client will not accept a
breaking change you can say hey here's a
here's a cranked id check i made just
run it on your code base and you
automatically upgrade the same way you
say hey run this on your db you will
have the latest schema it's exactly the
same thing here is a migration script
that goes with my breaking change so you
can actually continue working
and like i said cleaning all code
becomes much cheaper
again not an argument for having tight
depth
uh i don't know how long am i on time
but
this is the last part so it's perfect
so right if you have to remember like i
don't know three or four things the
first one is that
quality is worth the cost
because the cost sorry because
whatever you think your code is going to
be seen as an investment so invest in a
good investment
you can use tooling to save water
quality which is the first step making
sure that nothing gets worse and the
second step which is more about
automation is raising the quality level
and also raising it by using automation
not just manually spending like three
weeks of uh tag depth uh just like
removing or two pointers by hand because
that's that first of all you're never
gonna get a budget and two yeah yeah
like i said you burn programmers doing
that because we hate doing stuff that
can be repeated
it opens new horizons it's not just like
you can do stuff uh easily so you can
just do stuff that were basically
impossible before like i i'm not sure we
have seen the the
i think we've seen the beginning of the
paradigm i know some companies are more
advanced than others but i think we only
we haven't seen everything that people
can think about the the simple idea that
now you can maybe possibly distribute an
update of your library with a script
that says hey run this on your database
and on your code and then you can add up
the new version and yeah i could make a
breaking change because it's fine i
didn't break your usage here's effects
oh and did i mention randomness
i mean if you're gonna have to trust
robots to change your code you're gonna
have to trust them that they're not
lying to you when they actually run and
say yeah see the tests are still passing
i didn't break anything
if you want to know more uh i had only
space for two because they have very
long titles i was told by a colleague
that is actually a tactic to be sure
that if you uh that there is they have
all their for the name for themselves uh
the first one is an example from an old
co-worker my friend who runs the the
paris user group now
i think he did that for a gui library at
my previous company but i'm not entirely
sure anyway it's a pretty it's a good
introduction uh on what you can do with
it with example of how you how to write
your own tanks it's a very hot topic
every major conference has at least one
talk about what i did with lip tooling
uh cppcon has one every year cpp now has
one every year there's a bunch of them
and then if you want more to talk about
the theory the first part of quality
software capital and all that stuff like
a lot of the ideas i took about quality
come from the ideas of software capital
that was coined by david senkel 2006
uh pretty good talk uh some people have
said it should have been a keynote i
kind of agree
it's a long discussion about why you
want quality
and i mean it's made by a finance
company so i guess we know they know a
thing or two about investment
oh and furthermore
i think your bill should be destroyed
thank you
[Applause]